it's Facebook Monday I didn't know there
was a such thing as a Facebook Monday is
that right it's [ __ ] Monday whatever
you want dude my friends at my French
one big long Sunday that's what this
quarantine feels like one big long
Sunday my friend Dan told me that don't
wear blue one blue you first rule so
that's that's that's a [ __ ] lie
go blue on blue is a great look nope
this is malachite blue now if that's
true um uh the my friend told me that he
was with this girl he was hating and he
was literally they were kissing kissy
kissy and then she goes I want you to
[ __ ] my face all right
he was like okay she was such a sweet
yeah she was very shy in the [ __ ]
face she's shy [ __ ] stories Monday all I
didn't know a [ __ ] story my days you
said it's Facebook Monday yeah dude some
girl said I'm gonna grow my face [ __ ] my
face that's going on every second of the
day right now the question is if you'd
let me finish question is when you meet
a girl a beast be honest I what now be
honest you met you meet a girl you take
her out dinner she's sweet she's meek
you kissy Kissy and she goes [ __ ] my
face well it's wifey hold on now
now that's a very important questions I
don't think it is wifey I just think
about it for me it is I don't know maybe
what I'm right or me I think my days
crazy my dicks not think I understand it
does he disqualify her from wifey since
its first day who doesn't know it's like
a good time alright I don't know if I
believe is a positive every [ __ ] your
attitude I appreciate you saying on the
podcast but is that we discriminate all
right a lot of guys do they want them
they want to you know the Madonna [ __ ]
complex or in the bedroom
I'm not freaking the sheet yeah lay your
lady in the street then you got a lady
who's dead bad else then you want
somebody raising your kids that becomes
a complicated thing if it's lady in the
sheets [ __ ] that's a boring in the
streets
[ __ ] my face is that is that romantic no
that's not yeah you don't want boring in
the she's nah
I want horn the sheet
and beast in street what said Jim
Jeffries thing was [ __ ]
a girl girls a girl who let you bang her
in the in the in the booty who says it
was like on birthdays on your birthday
who says Jim Jefferies he goes it was in
[ __ ] and a good girl because I like
[ __ ] a good girl it's like a good girl
let you a section of legend let's have a
sex folder let's have sex and they and
the more and like in basically like you
know a birthday you know and holidays
and a [ __ ] as the girl is while you're
having sex with in the India's she's
like she's saying I can't wait for
another dick to be in my ass right now
without lying
yeah he's yeah interests oh nice girl
and [ __ ] there is yeah that's just a
video so don't we have them come on the
show soon yeah next Wednesday not this
week next one of the best to do it did
you yeah he's great did you watch the
the G caught up on the join stuff the
last dance did you watch like I have but
I didn't get to the rodman part because
I had trouble downloading
notes on the Sun yes p.m. I don't have
cable I said okay cancel my cable said
I'm gonna use it I was like I'll use
apps then I run into problems I got it I
got an Internet problem now sport I get
an Internet a couple things during the
quarantine try getting an Internet okay
I look up yeah and then try reporting a
stolen car now you know daddy has his
hobbies which also yeah but it's still
it's a Prius but you did it was your car
yeah and so I got you had it my buddy my
buddy driving he happened to have left
the keys in it
hey but he's a [ __ ] well he probably
was like what are the chances we all do
this I've never done that in my entire
37 years on this planet left keys in the
car well he's overnight no no it was he
went in to see his buddy he was gonna
his buddy was working out goes talk to
his buddies gonna come back out yeah
just like whatever I've never done it
well anyway somebody's probably rode by
on their bike and went let me get in
that talk to my brother as a cop who
said we run plates all day
usually they find it if you report it
right away I didn't really report it
right away you're a little and that's
that's Brian and nut so late it was
being reported by my friend and my
friend
friends into it cops said you're not the
registered owner you can't make a police
report because he's borrowing yes so now
I got to go through it and what I
realized is I I went to the police
department and they go I'm gonna walk in
and they laugh at you and they go for
reporter pretty nope they go uh no they
go can't come in here nobody in here
because of kovin I'm like ah so you
gotta call it in problem is when you
call it in it's gotta be in the right
districts and I got to find the right
district where it is where was all the
carbon yeah then they sent me a dispatch
guy then dispatch guy goes I never
report patrol car come out we're not
gonna do that
it took a long time they were very cool
they were very cool it for example and
you know what but during the cook during
kovat it's tough Cove it or not I'm just
glad they actually acted like they were
gonna search down this prius cuz you
know they don't get come on don't be
mean no but they run plates they might
they might find out though they're
looking for real they got real so should
this LA's finest they assured me you
know what was cool about every one of
them they go we're really sorry you're
having a bad day we're sorry this
happened to you I was like that's nice
you guys very nice I'll get back out
there
I appreciate that and I said stop
everything
hold everything and find this Prius and
find this Prius it's me tuft of prius
that's a tough Carter I don't like your
attitude that's a pretty just chalk it
up as a loss just right at mode already
you don't care could you lend it to your
friend I mean so it's like you don't
care for the car you know they're gay
it's a plug-in ass white yeah and you
don't drive this plug-in but you don't
drive it for selling yeah it's like
bicycles will pass you up yeah I'll get
on the e biking Davidoff called it he
goes a Prius a Prius otherwise known as
you can punch me in the face and I'll
never do anything right yeah I won't
I won't hit you back no matter what you
do to me yeah but the cops are saying
all right yeah we're on it I liked
having a red Prius you remember I read a
very gay very gay piece of maroon it's
like it was Barcelona red please get it
right Barcelona red day and it was
adorable and it was it little
than dishwasher with wheels and what's
cool about that is that nobody [ __ ]
with you likey guys in cars cops
everybody kind of like and what I got
pulled over let's go
I got that's it I got pulled over by a
cop and I and he said you know fast
you're gone I go officer I can explain
his wedding goes didn't have it in Eco I
had it in supercharged because you see
that the button here he laughs he
started laughing he let me off I'm a
[ __ ] I'm remember I had a Prius when
I was driving it was sure did I know it
was like my third car at a Prius just to
use it for camp stuff
I would eat I have [ __ ] name of food
I'd have salsa hot sauce on my head I'd
wipe it in the seats you know how you
hated that [ __ ] car I would walk out
car I'd kick it then get in it I hated
that guy
I don't know it was like a go-kart he
just didn't like it you have such a
problem with look at you back in the day
yeah I guess that looks so wrong
something about you and a Prius right
that's amazing yeah I trade that bad boy
I gave it back
you look different I mean yes it's a
nice car though all right I hated it I
mean it's just either great cry hey
there are the best cars in some ways and
that's not true of anything in some ways
they are they last I hated it they did
it yeah you're so slow you got problems
you need power it's so slow I mean
you're ridiculous though you're the
other end of the extreme yeah you drive
a rs200 ours too
what does it cost just to just say you
drive Poor's though well no what does it
call what is gt2 all right a GT 2 RS
sorry dude
give a [ __ ] but it's your primary car I
do respect that I respect cuz my uncle
had sports cars and never drove them and
cover them like you get them in a car
with a car cover ya know and will drive
them literally once a month if for like
couple hours on a Sunday I'm like I'll
get a point you drive the [ __ ] out of
that it's your only car I don't think
anybody does that I don't know anyone
who does it yeah I Drive the piss out of
it though yeah I Drive the piss out
thing now his dad now is daddy getting
it tuned in two weeks to get to 900
horsepower yeah
is because the gentleman reached out who
knows what he's doing
your sons I went why not huh
I just want a 900 horsepower 900 yep
what does that mean what does that mean
for your driving we'll think of a horse
right think of a giant hole wall think
of Clydesdale now think I'll bake that
thing all right think of it in the
studio now tell me 9:00 we'll just think
of a big horse tied up by 899 I'm not
going and then think of all the powers
of them running at once hey that's my
closet at it yeah yeah I I don't know if
that's true but I okay I don't have it
no wait that's how they measure for yeah
but I like it I like it horsepower it's
a kind of course gives when pulling why
do we still pretty awesome analogy
because it's just good works it works
some things you don't want to [ __ ] with
some things just work there's some
really weird things that that's that
last like bicycles girl bikes to this
day a girl's going it doesn't have a bar
yeah it just has this just now sloped
it's just a feminine it's the same thing
well no but not mountain bikes no oh
yeah I'm sure mountain bikes were
different but elodie bikes are different
but if you go to buy like a most bikes
yeah the girls have still don't have the
bar do you rid of the banana seat and
and I look at a car nice double blue
banana seat my grandma taught me humphy
oh yeah kind of genius actually
dude I would toss a banana seat on my
new bike right lad though even with
mountain bikes you gotta wear women's
mountain bikes these yeah but with a
softer bar it's so interesting others
are normal bars like this that's a
mountain bike bars are Wow but straight
across this is gonna be bad really yeah
okay
those are normal huh now the pink and
[ __ ] yes pretty feminine but pink is
nothing they there are they've studied
that boys for whatever on in general
prefers the color blue girls prefer the
color pink it's a it's actually a
biological thing it's so weird
that's so [ __ ] weird to me it's not
so Society it's actually for whatever
reason women are drawn to that color
little girls pink and boys are drawn to
blue and
then variations on that theme yeah boys
like red nice banana see what happened
to those they make so much more sense
than what was right
banana seats are great yeah how come how
come you wouldn't have a banana seat I
read a bloom I see a banana like my
grandpa made it for me
really yeah banana seats are sold school
yeah yeah they're all I don't know if
you can buy them anymore yeah I like to
sniffing oh I sniff banana seats when
then did the town pervert walk around
sniffing your bike's eatin it's not much
more than that bike seat right now it's
we're on the mound bike the bike seats
they're pretty small man like did I hurt
my [ __ ] and they go you can now you
have like you know when you change the
gears on the left side you push it and
heat goes up and down really yeah I hurt
your doesn't it hurt you how people are
saying that like go enjoy your paint
have no issues really it's not a policy
I've no issue but that area isn't
exactly muscular it's hard to get muscle
on your taint but I've been riding that
peloton like two or three years now I
think it's used to it that little callus
on your on your taint yeah it's a sumo
wrestler yeah no thought brown hair is a
little spongy but you must have a little
bow stuff a little bit there like a
battleship right under your balls right
under your nutters I feel bit like you
like just some mollusk uh-huh yeah but
yeah you can control the seat down and
up just when you're going down like if
you're going down the Mount you don't
want it all the way up does any other
[ __ ] hit special bike shorts Jack uh I
have some spandex I'll bust I'll be down
there is that right I do what do you do
with your dick well I just done it tuck
it in there's a guy white guy
preppy white looking guy very nice hair
probably 28 on the way here he's on he's
right on Lincoln Boulevard he is selling
masks he's in a Superman costume I'm
gonna take a picture I should have taken
prisoner he's in a Superman costume
here's that with a mask of blue gloves
and he's holding face masks he's selling
them and I can see his shitty dick he's
not wearing underwear I can see the
outline perfectly of this shitty dick
and he's wondering why no one's buying
his mask I was like how the [ __ ] did
that huh I can understand if you have to
sell mass in your maybe doesn't know
he just doesn't know his dicks hanging
out he I looked at him and I went this
is the whole this is the whole problem
with you I'm gonna get on the way back I
hope he's still there but I went the
discussion I was getting my 10-speed
coffee this morning there's a gift
there's a guy at his father's bike and I
wanted to get out my phone and record
him but it'd been too obvious and maybe
just offensive
he was the thickest of boys and he
clearly a bear clearly a gay man okay
oiled up and he had basically a singlet
on he had this deep singlet all the way
down this belly button it just chest
hair and he's on this [ __ ] bike and I
want to post eviction me like leader of
the sick boys bike club hey but I
thought probably not is what if he sees
this yeah that's the problem so he came
him it was he in Venice just riding
around ten speeds right off center when
you say thick you talking about fat or
just big barrel-chested kind of big old
fire hydrant beer a big old man not like
didn't have fat hand a big bear you know
ha yeah thick guy
boxcar Willie round round with a big old
hairy chest dumb fat dumb thick as they
call it dumb thing you and I know
somebody who's gay I'll tell ya affair
and I said he goes something like the
guys my type too and I said what he like
he goes I like I like guys who are heavy
I like I like I have no problem with a
bare belly and I like him big really big
and I was like mmm we see the world so
differently I don't know our friend yeah
I'll tell you about the comic I don't
know I'll tell you about it
is racing well some girls like that do
mm-hmm
some girls like oh hundred percent some
girls I know man I knew a girl who I had
sex with in New York I'll never forget
and she said I like guys with bellies I
just like a big kind of guy belly and a
little older than you
oh well why didn't you ask for I mean
she just likes I was asking her to
describe it it was so a lien to me I
said what is it what about a bellies
because I just like a guy you know a guy
who like it she goes something like she
said no guy who works he comes home and
he's got a a tool belt and he's got a
bell he well gonna be hard to find three
like what the [ __ ] she goes I just like
that kind of with I was like it has to
be maybe when she was a kid it's like
something maybe like the plumber under
course of course you know there's a one
woman I knew who loved very hairy men
you know hunter a lot ski oh yeah
remember how hairy he was I showed her a
picture do
I sure her picture of him and she lost
her - because oh yes shoulder said yeah
bring up young are having shoulders I
mean he was so [ __ ] tough to see what
you can see the way in picture ever
looked at him there
oh no when he shaved down he was shaved
down Bob back in the day he was so
[ __ ] hairy it was crazy
not even hairier I thought that's max
that's in there that's about max
Orlovsky Jesus but yet here on the
shoulders yeah too bad no it was a stern
shave Dave Herman's the bad one yeah
Dave the gun Dave Herman I thought there
but she said she [ __ ] see off did the
more a hair the better see that oh Jesus
that's a hairy dude I kind of appreciate
it though I kind of he's such an animal
good body I don't mind it doesn't look
bad on him in a way heavy weight what
does he know about you that's a big kid
he's a [ __ ] caveman you may as well
be just overly hairy but she would lose
her mind she said she had a teacher who
had he would wear a Rolex watches and he
had big forearms and he was you couldn't
see a skin you couldn't see it and she
that was her first and he she was a kid
and she that was her first idea of what
a man was that's Chris yeah that guy's a
boxer he's a Russian guy cat do you like
hairy dudes I'm not the biggest fan I
would say not but maybe not like but you
don't want to like smooth like a seal
smooth like it's like a seal I'm down
with oh really more so we're so then
real here yeah real hairy
I guess most young guys shave their
pubes even they shave everything do you
know this I think they trim their pubes
I hear they shave it clean bomb yeah
conv
who told you this I've talked to some
people and it's very calm I don't think
so you're young is that true or not they
trim them bushes are out at in all most
guys shave everything just like girls do
now I
or come in now and then it used to be
but I still don't think that's super
prevalent that people are just shaving
everything or at least guys trim yes I
don't know about shaving I go on the
dating forums and I can tell you the
dating form are you deep into reticle
Dondre oh so fine I don't know men yeah
I think yet here's kind of out right
pretty swish with a younger demo yeah I
mean hair is fine as long as you're kind
of keeping good keeping up good hygiene
like the whole Demi Moore thing with
like a bit much you know
oh god like it's fine to have hair just
have a respectable amount you know
what's weird is that last night on that
uh that last dance episodes 3 & 4 is on
Dennis Rodman and during the middle of
the season he just like I need a break
I'm sickness I need a break and Michael
Jordan and Phil Jackson I call right to
take it well let you do you be back in
48 hours
go to Vegas come back because I need to
go to Vegas just on his motorcycle
cruises to Vegas his growth times Carmen
Electra so he's out there just doing
crank out Lord's work yeah but Carmen
Electra is honestly is on the
documentary like currently yeah dude she
is a smoke she still looking god but I
work with her Bubba
yes smoosh I worked with her and she's
she's a great person she was so [ __ ]
good she had to beat me up and fat
actress and I just I have nothing but
good Wow good for her nearly shoulder
look are lysed
looking good dude she was it remembers
you either a car or lecture or Pamela
I'm Cynthia I like both I work with both
spent a week with both because I spend
spend a week with both ladies
cremeluxe were very pretty and an
awesome person Pam Anderson it wasn't
cool best of all time
well personally better looking in person
oh wow oh kill you and cool both I'm
really cool actually I have to say but
Conor electro looks so much better than
Pam Anderson now
probably they seem to him lately no you
got up Justin she had hep-c and
she went through treatment I don't know
saying all that I'm saying current
physical yeah well you know listen aged
as a [ __ ] dude but when she was
younger forget
it well I said I still take Carmen
Electra man when we currently I mean
Pam's not bad yeah they're got Pamela
sexy dying me peace oxygen ridiculous
yeah so he's a criminal extra fan though
when she was smoking dude my girlfriend
at the time was friends with her a
little bit and she came home she just
dresses like she just has no problem
dressing like a complete stripper like
she would just they'd go out and she'd
be wearing basically pasty he's
practically got it I know but she was
really cool yeah Karen Electra said
because Rodman is only supposed to gun
for 48 hours and Michael Jordan told
Phil Jackson like dude he's not using me
gun way long in 40 hours and feels like
now he'll be back
sure enough four days go past he's still
in Vegas so Jordan flew out there and
knocked on his hotel door Jordan do that
and Carmen Electra said she was so
scared she hid but she's she was I was
naked so I put a sheet over my head and
just hid where he can't see me
what and my cousin was like get your ass
to [ __ ] practice really yeah so so I
always wondered about that relationship
because I know Jordan ran all those
[ __ ] I mean you'd hear him in
games like are you afraid you want to
win you know but I feel like yeah he'd
say he said it afraid you guys a little
wish he'd say he said that he goes are
you afraid you want to win because I'm
not with you here say that yeah there's
a thing I know it sounds silly but he
actually screamed wants to win
everything he's a white guy from Serbia
one of those guys so but my question is
I never saw him it seemed like he never
he and Rodman
kind of avoided each other like Devils
huh really no they were pretty hot it
was wild everywhere else especially when
I went to San Antonio it was good on
Detroit you won the same Detroit and
then he got traded and when he went to
the Bulls right he was like Rodman I'm
Jordan Pippen were so respectable and
like new Rodman was gonna be this loose
cannon but as long as performed they
were cool yeah so Ron was good yeah cuz
he let them really but he because he
knew his job and he knew Jordan Scottie
word because he didn't need the ball he
didn't want to score he didn't want to
rebound freak I forgot it's interesting
man because they show all the guys you
know currently and then they show when
they're playing everybody thick Wow
everybody's age everybody think yeah
even joy like damn die
yeah that's Michael Jordan the great
bald on you looking like what struck me
was how South in he was when he was
playing when he first got got out of
college he this is so skinny like they
put thing get started lifting put on
weight yeah yeah but man and and when
you see his speed I've never seen that
class speed it was so was such a
different speed it was like myself he
would get called him a traffic doula
Brahmas I know he'd get called for
traveling because he was so fast
all the time yeah here's the thing dude
what's funny is that episode 1 & 2
everyone's feeling sorry for Scottie
Pippen FY he made more money than Jordan
over his NBA career look it's right here
LeBron Trey young settles the goat
debate click on that for me for me bar
Jordans by far the goat just because he
so every accolade
LeBron's ever had Jordan had plus he won
that dunk contest which LeBrons too
afraid to do he doesn't want to put he
does want to risk it so the best player
in they made don't do the dunk contest
anymore cuz the reason I can't you know
what just pull I forgot that Kobe did
you saw come around oh dude hidey-ho be
dumb ik will can I direct sir Michael
Jordan the best of the best always did
it yeah Larry Johnson's Carter yeah oh
yeah the best of the best of the
superstars you should do it now
everyone's too scared to get hurt
they're too scared to you know to
receive criticism they don't think
they're gonna win they don't do it
anymore
back in the day the guys did it yeah so
join one dunk contest MVP NBA MVP Finals
MVP Defensive Player of the Year so it's
like so sick LeBron's never meet defense
Player of the Year now let's do a couple
q and A's so while many often debate so
so some said who's your best so he said
my top five LeBron James Jordan Kobe
Katie Steve Nash who is try so he just
thinks he's a really good NBA player
from play to Oklahoma is your [ __ ]
beast
interesting
but I think I think if you're a younger
guy you're gonna go with LeBron James
it's just what you know it's like if you
ask me what the greatest movie is all
time mine yeah exactly my perspectives
me so much different than yours very
true so so much different I aboard who's
the greatest band of all time minded me
so much cats isn't me so much different
than chance because it depends what area
you grew up in the question is if you
have to choose one player out of that
list first Michael Michael yeah
clutch she's defense your heart of a
warrior yeah monster led the league and
all those things that's really important
did you see uh you also have to take
into account
you just have to the fact that Michael
was smaller than LeBron and still was
able to you know achieve more that that
physical difference is I wasn't I mean
Michaels not small magazine it was he
was six six but LeBron six nine 265
that's a significant size difference
with great speed so phenomenal athlete
very muscular but that that plays a part
you have an advantage I feel like when
you're that that big in that fast
so the question yeah I wonder if LeBron
is working with the same tools you can't
be that that's so silly that's so silly
bit yeah maybe it doesn't make a
difference after a while that size three
inches is significant though didn't the
go conversation will include that it's
you know yeah it does they have to
include it you have to how tall was Kobe
six seven yeah what's the honk [ __ ] you
were on it I can do it at age 31
LeBron averaged 27 points Mike glad
averaged 32 nowhere near as many
rebounds
oh my Chris Michael yeah yeah he's not
as big
he just a blob Ron can get in there and
bang I always say who would you rather
have on your team who's who has a
greater impact who leads you to victory
I mean I mount in you know wrong with
either no puffs because what LeBron did
against the goal State Warriors
shitty Cleveland team and one that's
insane the greatest of all time it's
hard to say many thank you you know
you're never gonna win you're fine with
everybody you're never gonna win well
I've seen Kobe in person couple of times
he looks taller than six six he's a
freak
Saint yummy Charles Barkley it was six
four threes like see ya oh my lord
oh yeah he's like seven four I think oh
he was a stud too for a while but he's
too big so you know his body just breaks
down dude did you see her the rumors
that that kim jeong-hoon died yeah we
have on credit it's all fake yes often
they came out he's perfectly fine mama I
know I thought you dead - I know it's
all fake [ __ ] I was actively hoping he'd
died with you
you got us again North Korea he's got
he's has happened before - I thought her
really came out and made a statement
saying nothing's out out of the ordinary
with North Korea and he's definitely
still alive they'd just be leaking
shitty luck great fantastic he suffers
from severe gout smokes like a chimney
and eats of [ __ ] were these five seven
three hundred pounds good stuff let me
see his face easy 300 pounds yes he's
only five seven yes mister his face said
yeah look look at that [ __ ] he's in his
30 still all right 36
she's only 36 yeah she's a nice guy look
at that [ __ ] a few were if you were to
patent when it doesn't matter let me see
if he passes away who do would replace
them
we'll be so uncool but probably not yeah
yeah wait how things travel man how's it
go sick definitely dead nope yeah
nothing unusual that's a bummer
hmm one who started it
who starts that [ __ ] well he did you
show up - yeah the most important
holiday in North Korea which is the
April 15th commemoration parade of his
grandfather who was essentially the
founder of the dear leader the great
leader the the fountain did he give an
excuse why his job no which is you know
nobody ever does so now they might be
lying he's okay no idea hopefully
suffering very badly the bad die huh
yeah yeah the story was that he had a
heart surgery that was botched and it
left him in a vegetative state or
brain-dead but then people are coming
out saying that that's not true I mean I
mean your boy Dennis Rodman seems to be
friends that [ __ ] guy is that weird
that's such an unlikely friendship it's
so weird
when they asked Rodman about like all
the horrible stuff you think hey listen
I don't touch on that I don't know about
anything that's though he starts a lot
of bad stuff too and yeah it's tough
seeing Robin two men and it was he's
definitely weird yeah all the piercings
in his nose he's always had that though
even when he's playing at the Pearson's
lip nose but I heard that he went crazy
once his son he had he lost custody of
son is it a truly crazy
always always he has a color thing with
his face - yeah that's impetigo it looks
like he's losing something Wow is that
the same as a bit alike Oh father time
um yes that's what I mean I think it's a
bit alike oh I don't know if that's true
but that's what it looks like but he
likes to dress and drag sort of a lot
cast with them
I suppose do a podcast oh I'm gonna I
committed to it and then it's in Newport
and this is when there's bad traffic I
was like yet new not
that the arrived it was like you know
they take me two and a half hours to get
there on scout let me just see what's
podcast about I don't if he's still
doing it it was it was him giving
relationship advice and having two
couples on I was like what are we I
don't wanna be part of this man I don't
know if they're still doing it no he's a
such a character he is such a character
yeah I was wondering what guys like that
do on a day to day basis you know like
well you know he made so much money
hopefully they're good there but then
yeah but I mean what is this all why not
my outfit that's a great beetlejuice
good I really him yeah looks like wow
damn teeth Wow yeah just a different
bird he is a different bird man he's a
different bird he'll actually shake it
up
okay did he date her I guess it's so
funny when you see him it's almost like
a puzzle you're like what's he doing now
it's like cool smooth you know yeah she
was such this is something else back in
the day
Russia her own show yeah then she got
like on that medication and just passed
away she lost her son I know
and then she was bad man yeah I like to
show
I never she was smoking hot back in the
day did that old battle-ax she was
hilarious I watched some of the court
things that she did hilarious she had a
sense of humor look at her though I mean
good that's the one that she married
yeah come on he loved her well yes he
did definitely a [ __ ] scheme he left
her a lot of money I mean all our money
I left nothing to the family I know I
want you to fought the son and daughter
kind of have their thing
if you she was crying cause like this
she was like and I miss him and Loara
first son goes how are your acting
classes coming and she she screw you
rusty oh yeah screw you rusty that's
right she was a smoke show but then on
that on her show on I think it was eat
yeah I met her I met her cuz I got a
show with her I did a little thing in
Vegas with her and she was so out of it
like even on stage she was just a matter
of yeah man she was just like thanks boy
yeah her lawyer yeah it was a whole
weird thing right when she passed away
yeah
she's got real sick towards the end
there men yeah I think you're right when
I said she looked healthy there I think
when her when her son passed away Ken
it's all downhill from there yeah yeah
what he died just he's a beautiful kid
too
he died from drugs [ __ ] pretty sure it
was drugs [ __ ] these drugs speaking of
drugs I for the first time took half an
adderall somebody said here's an
adderall is good for ADHD and I wanted
to write and I was like should I take it
and I took it I took half an adderall
hey guys for me that's cocaine yeah it's
nem feta mean yep I'm like but I I'm
high I'm on cocaine
the adderall I was like that this isn't
helping me it makes me feel good and I
feel like I have a lot of energy when I
was like I don't know III I'm not doing
it again cuz I like it if it may as well
be cocaine but the help you focus I
attend I was at a party where a bunch of
girls gave they were they all did pills
and I went what are you guys doing and
they go it's adderall you want something
I go no what is that and they were like
oh it's great now I know why they took
you take a lot of adderall you're gonna
feel [ __ ] amazing really oh dude you
stay away from it look at me right now
look at me right now stay away from me
oh you like kratom you like [ __ ]
nicotine you stay away from matter all
cuz you never done cocaine I've done
cocaine alright stay away from that too
but firfer for guile x energy stay away
from that all mirror in the cuz it's
good over at Sunday if a guy came in the
bathroom my highest [ __ ] like okay oh my
god that was hilarious
whoa and he was making the matrix yep I
mean yep I remember that he smelled
strong I didn't know his breath was
awful and I already body did while he do
and I was like what the [ __ ] gonna be
like you think okay yeah Wow
like Oprah it was great it was [ __ ]
great yeah um you stay away from
adderall get my hair but I'll tell you
what man it's you feel fantastic what do
you take what it's a stimulant you take
for ADHD so when you want to focus you
want to stay up all night and write your
paper or whatever it might be you would
take adderall so a lot of students do
know I took out a row another kid when I
was in college I ran is just a Chatty
Cathy yeah got nothing done nothing just
like I was like I was like I feel
amazing so I'm coming up see up like hey
what are you doing and then just talk
there's off you didn't get any work it's
like that that the first high you get
from coffee quadruple I'm always chasing
that yeah we all are
we all are I drink coffee I'll admit it
because I've been chasing that [ __ ]
feeling from day one look up in Atlantic
never I'll get a little when you can
drink as much coffee as I do you get
this for a second you get one second
like we'll see I got a drink another oh
yeah I'm tonight ah [ __ ] any coffee
right before Ben adderall will keep you
a good going I need to get something
please don't know why don't do it
have you done a chance amphetamines all
you have some I can get so which I won't
from this is prescription narcotic it's
huh it's a [ __ ] aunt Fatima J I can
get some who's listening can you tell me
what the side effects are at or are they
bad for your heart when you're my age
with it's an amphetamine look it up
first if you have issues you know what
google it [ __ ] that there's a there's a
there's an feta mean there's vyvanse
which is a time-release adderall but up
but I think if as long as you take a
controlled amount because there's kids
on that [ __ ] I understand fortunately
there's kids on adderall can damage can
yep
can cause damage to the heart I don't
when you one use for prolonged if you
just do on the weekend use Nexus the
most common ADH medication
cardiovascular problems reported are
hypertension high blood pressure and
tomorrow I'd be right yeah yeah but I
wonder what the odds are of how many
people statistically suffer from that I
bet the majority people are just fine
yeah it's not overdo well that's like
when I said bro pre-show cause
depression and your dick won't be as
hard my dick Oh cut a diamond I couldn't
be happier so it depends on a person
yeah all that being said I want to try
it though they can cause effects such as
elevated heart rate and blood pressure
increased risk of heart attack stroke
you don't read this [ __ ] I mean we could
look up anything if you guys have any
type of heart issues at all with high
blood pressure and there's life so far
all right
we don't know you get a look bring it on
but don't ever try cocaine though I
would say that for a fact if you like
kratom and if you like and I'll lose
weight painkillers and all those might
ask me if I have cocaine oh I know a guy
that has been to old drugs lately huh no
I don't do I can't do that stuff but
yeah the answer is yes but I don't have
well if you put out a roll or anything
you put right now with this [ __ ]
thing if you put any truck in front of
me I might do it I'm weak I get bored at
night let me - I'll drink whiskey I
drink you know but no I still the point
is I did adderall it felt too good now I
know I'm not gonna do it it feels that
good I ain't buying it I'm not buying
yeah I did half an adderall I can't have
you le collateral I know Bach never
lateral gnosis Elton College
oh no I considered telling xanax to kids
college
have you ever that Vanek no me neither
what's Danny do it's supposed to tell
you out it's anxiety medicine my mother
swears by it I don't she'll take 1/2 1/4
1/8 as you see if you go to sleep it's
actually it's anxiety medicine Prozac
do you take anything today uh no I
considered getting prescription just to
sell to rich college students back in
the day but now you don't take you me I
don't take anything ever do tell you
think gin I take kratom every day which
I don't I don't think people should take
it by the way people think I'm like
promoting it I don't promote it at all I
just do it myself
yeah yeah I understand some people you
know I think everybody's different
everybody's biology is different and I
you no matter if it works for some
people five aunts that [ __ ] you know
it's but they do use that as a party
drug everyone uses of course no no I
dude I couldn't believe it I'm not
kidding when I tell you it can you not
sleep on it oh it's so hard to sleep
don't ya yeah I was up I took a half a
one at 12:00 cuz I wanted to do some
writing and I was told and III was up
til well I about 12 hours
I was very awake for 12 hours but it
feels down Joyce
it feels having that motor motor Phil
what'd they give pilots modafinil no
predict provisional provincial your boy
got a hold of that yeah that stuff I can
take that stuff work out like a madman
and sleep just fine
yeah it plug goes through your body they
say that's like that has the effect of
like a lot of espresso I don't know if
provigil is nan said I mean it might be
but but it is every wall is an enemy no
it's an amphetamine cuz there it is
verse a dural
to compare mm-hmm is a schedule for drug
whereas a schedule 2 drug aha high risk
for abuse oh so I should manic is my
probe ill both drugs similar side
effects such as anxiety and you snap
that's what you like her to Krishna
adderall is I can see it being 100%
addictive yeah just like coke oh yeah
people addicted to it for sure
yeah and I want to try some now
I'm telling you you'll like it too much
stay away and you'll be a secret user
but what's the worst that's gonna happen
this war I mean you just can't get off
it I always worry about that stuff
oh yeah but you will [ __ ] yeah take the
best coffee how you've ever had in
quadruplet and it's just a know what you
know what the bummer is is my my talents
we'll get to that and then keep it well
my god Martin it was called Pro Ville
here provisionally I had that right and
I would take one pill and first I'd be
feeling great do my workout be [ __ ]
pumpin and then a few weeks go by and
that one pill not doing too much for me
yeah your big sorry no you know it's not
about being big your body just gets used
to it's like coffee
no matter your size dude it's just the
coffee the caffeine and think your body
gets used to it so you keep have to up
it up and then it just doesn't work
mmm-hmm well I mean vyvanse
is control it's a I think vyvanse is a
control release or whatever right our
time release so that might be a little
better um if you don't need it just
don't do it at all though I don't know
why we're recommending I'm not
recommending like I'm not recommending
it what I'm saying is that I've heard it
let's stop I'm riding I've heard that
I'm not I've heard adderall and so are
you no I'm not
I heard a definitely convinced everybody
no listen I heard Hatter all and they
said don't do coke people talk about
adderall as it's like that's just a drug
no no no it's a powerful stimulant that
feels just like okay and he says the
best thing you've ever done
I'm saying you shouldn't do it because I
can see how people would do it all the
time have you done oxycontin no I've not
done it I have you have you have oh yeah
it's would you but I don't like it
because I think it's been a natural
it's a I don't like down it's yeah but I
mean the pink opiate that's how
painkillers are pretty much Downers but
then it makes you feel really warm and
good yeah which sense people should
never do of those one beer your night is
set or wine and but it's so addictive
and then your
life just goes up and down hell yeah
this episode is brought to you by the
deer I need a half a pill adderall know
that that's the devil yeah stay the [ __ ]
away from it I'll call you hard I seen
espresso beans chocolate-covered
espresso beans [ __ ] I'd wonder where
I was shaking I took a caffeine pill
when I was a kid and when I was in high
school and I I couldn't express the
beans don't do [ __ ] for anybody make
chocolate ones yeah no I drank a fire a
fuckload oh oh dude in in college before
we were lifted at CU we took a bunch of
caffeine pills well the problem is we
take too much of those you're gonna [ __ ]
your promise so yeah we all took that on
like six pills
they're like hundred milligram dude we
were to barely see straight yeah and
everybody [ __ ] their pants yeah that's
as strong it's a good time yes but I
adderall that's why I should do adderall
well everybody uses it adderall is used
by I mean yeah it's I gotta be honest
fellas I'm not in these circles everyone
saw about how I've been around any
circuits what they use for ADHD so how
many kids are prescribed it that tons
how many people use it to get their work
done in college tons it is made widely
used rum comics are tons
yeah well that's comics comics user I
don't know if you've noticed how much
cocaine is around a lot that's not
surprised you never been like you're
this old and you never tried it I'm
super surprised so definitely don't try
it then I don't think I would know if
this mark Brendan Brendan will try
something for a while and then well I've
just heard too many horror stories of
cocaine you at all sure yeah I'm not
that's gonna [ __ ] my life up sound like
cocaine like [ __ ] like a new at Iran be
flying all right same time same I
thought might be a cleaner hi that's I'm
worried like if you do out at all you
probably want to try cocaine yeah but
it's the same [ __ ] I would say a knurled
for me adderall is better here you'll
promote me I'll do not have promoting it
and there's a job done no don't use I'm
adderall should be treated like cocaine
I'm serious I didn't realize that see
this is coming from the guy who got high
off chocolate-covered espresso and take
a [ __ ] Flynn took a half a pill and I
was [ __ ] up in a good way
yeah I have a question for Brian yeah so
you done cocaine before yes back in the
day have you had sex on cocaine yes I
yeah and your dick is fine
Oh depending on the coke oh okay you
know that's best sex I've ever had might
be on cooking why because you you try to
chin I'm not saying I did it didn't but
I'm saying you've heard of it I've heard
that word up oh yeah I know of a dude
nothing well so sometimes worse with
blow and a feta means you can't get it
up it depends on your chemistry and your
constitution depends on the kind of boy
never had whiskey dick yeah from bridges
alcohol whiskey dude
sometimes you can do blow and it'll make
you dig hard immediately
huh that sounds interesting yeah does
that roll [ __ ] your boners I would
imagine it probably does dude no no
imagine doesn't owe in a good way
I imagine yeah I'd imagine depending on
who you are maybe it makes you wanna
bang decrease interest in sex so it is a
side effect on tential side effects such
a shame at my age I don't know man and
not not for me that Natalie took that
out of Bill yeah okay maybe the same guy
chocolate espresso beans and third
aspirin dudes I never said that dear
that's what you said then you can't like
what do you you can't draw that
conclusion I mean I remember I don't
remember if the chocolates I love a
chocolate sure a nice chocolate espresso
bean I just suck on coffee beans as a
kid yeah I've always been the coffee man
yep we have some Kurt Yvette's
yes we do okay so Pete Davidson has been
doing a bunch of SNL like mock music
videos from home and well SNL's trying
to stay on the air so they're just like
they gave all the talent like their cell
phones like do videos mm-hmm that's
essentially wasn't competence been doing
yes how home he's been making parody
like music videos he
- a Drake song the good and then this
one is one that he did with Adam Sandler
hit it and his mom directed it whole
there's he lives with his mom he is a
strange-looking cat yeah different like
a dude yeah he wrote this mm-hmm it's
good stuff that's his sister yeah I
think so midge was a mom and sister this
is great well that was [ __ ] great
that's cool that's really cool
and so now that Tom Hanks and his wife
have completely been oh okay from the
corona scare that they had where they
were quarantined there now donating
their blood to different places that are
gonna work on a vaccine Thanks and he
says should be called the Hank kissing
yeah he was just kind of joking around
but well just saw him do more raps
oh my son Chet but boy as more time
passes by he's growing on me
yeah I can't miss them what's he doing
these days I went on a weird rabbit hole
watching all his music videos they're
not even that sick chairs like they're
not even that sick yeah they're fine no
Instagram resource people are not really
that's yeah let me see is in Susie
what's he doing these days
still doing music check it out in my
head check it out of my head play that
[ __ ] Jen oh man okay
I wonder I wonder how I wonder how he
does does it sell how do you don't know
magic though right you just upload it
like a podcast on soundcloud do you
anyway and they get like five cents for
every stream well what I think is
interesting is is that your father being
Tom Hanks does absolutely nothing to get
people listen your music no right like
snapped it might hurt yes that's right
it might hurt you it's actually a hole
to get out of it you feeling it Jim did
you start rapping let's see oh do you
see post Malone and Travis Barker
covered nirvana I was awesome I mean
he's doing it though you know
I don't he's bad I wasn't mad at that I
bet it all I mean he's bad I really
don't
did you see post Malone and Travis
Barker coming Nirvana though they were
all post mom's house [ __ ] really make
sure you come at its come as yours the
big one he's the real deal isn't he
possible oh yeah absolutely
so [ __ ] talented what might be better
than the original okay she's gonna warn
ya I believe it he's wearing a dress
well that's what Kurt Cobain did you're
not [ __ ] good he is look at this guy
look at you no heart he's you know
people like to karaoke and [ __ ] this guy
his voice sounds totally different than
it normally does mhm
that's when you see these [ __ ] dudes
when you see like puts Maloney does that
song Wallflower whatever the [ __ ] and
and then you see then go and then you
see them go oh what do you want me to do
you want to play some song that you've
been listening to you want you want to
hear a classic and with the guitar watch
me do it better let your freak yeah I
didn't think he was gonna be my first
sign yeah I guarantee this with 50 songs
a hundred songs he's great yeah he's so
tell I mean his voice sounds great where
his voice sounds totally different he's
doing Kirk oh man he does everything
yeah yeah I mean yeah I didn't really
ever I wouldn't consider him a rapper
no he's a songwriter right I didn't
realize he started he started
but he started writing songs yeah I
guess he had formal training in music
probably did he already teach him you
know I taught himself the video game
some people just means our hero some
people just full you just start playing
guitar I was like ah [ __ ] I'm gonna sort
of doing the real thing cuz he's good at
that it's what he's supposed to do
let's not tattoo our face but I think he
looks better with the face tattoos than
he did without that guy or occasion I
thought when he's a little thinner and
but I don't it works for him look good
it works for what uh what I ever saw was
this big one mm-hmm what's that white
Iverson yeah what's his real name
Richard post yep
Austin Richard post Austin post Austin
post school - I don't know about getting
always tired underneath my eyes but all
right well it's a unique individual
though you know yes uh-huh
he looks cool I agree it's cool he's got
good luck yeah it's cool he was weird in
the beginning but it works now because
he's so talented
yeah it doesn't work if he's the night
just a very smart guy in a lot of ways
- other thing every time I've ever been
around people like this like if I was
doing MADtv and we had a guest
whether it was Queen Latifah our MC Lyte
or any of those back in the day they
were always just so [ __ ] smart and so
professional like ice ice ice tea not
ice cubed ice tea another one I worked
with ice tea is here comes this gangster
rapper and this is in 1997 when he was
like really a big deal and you know he's
kind of a rough dude he had people there
and it didn't smile and we start going
over the sketch right the [ __ ]
is coming up with suggestions that are
working it's comedy and he's going but I
don't know why I do this maybe if we do
this now I went oh this guy's good he
was a ranger in the military very very
disciplined guy but it was just so
interesting to see how discipline how
good he was and already a totally
different genre just smart [ __ ] smart
his wife was such a bit oh my god Coco
the hottest the hottest thing in the
world when she was a kid and it looks
identical to ice-t really they look I
did when she was younger
she was so impossible hot yeah there to
show on vh1 or E is she was such a
baddie giant hit yeah yeah I mean she
does look like ice-t doesn't that that's
a little energy yeah she's a baddie what
else you got the others did the North
Korea wanna this is hmm this is are
forcing her son back day just crush that
skinny one though right happen any day
yeah
did it crazy he that any baby she got
the genes uh-huh he's pretty sure he's
just like his papa
yep they look identical come on oh he's
his papa holy [ __ ] that's crazy dad had
the exact same bill
yeah that's [ __ ] nuts he looks just
like his that was incredible yeah
imagine trying to deny that's your son
and you look at that's not mine like
listen that's your son Annie that's
built like an armadillo doesn't have
these genetics Wow holy [ __ ] he's just
like his dad yeah that is a mean thing
is that a very close right yes yeah it
looks now he looks just like his dad
that is so cool is he giving you a
bodybuilding yeah he's totally into it
huh I mean you kind of have to you know
know the other kids did I think because
he looks so much like I'm he has his
physique he has to buy just no other
choice
yeah yeah his dad's haircut - Oh
fantastic
that makes me happy for some reason we
need another young Arnold in this world
oh I like this is this cool right so
it's like a couple goals I'll play for
you this is all day
yeah great so he plays for the Chiefs
right Kansas City or something like that
it's the Redskins the Redskins
so that's Kela Cason and her boyfriend
TJ Thorpe from the Redskins yeah that's
a cute again you and I should have a
hands let's do one please hold on there
yeah do it too gay Oh easy cowboy
easy cowboy I'm living my life over here
man don't be grabbing at the root hey I
need to be dead honest with me right now
yeah
are you addicted to Adderall look dude
how I've been thinking about it up the
way you were hyping it up I I'm not an
addictive personality but I'll tell you
this I can very much see myself coming
out with excuses to take that [ __ ] do it
hey you're not very helpful at all man
you want me down I will see you spiral
out of control let me down the rabbit
rein you back up oh boy
my heart what what if I caused a heart
problem
well I don't want to have to have a
valve surgery like kim jeong-hoon
disappear hmm is he oh I want to get fat
powerful you know this where Quinn enjoy
the OL chin yeah sneezes and gos bless
you hey so this is like an old one this
is from back then I'll play the
dedication of different carats of these
my right now I got a ATO wrote something
so I'm gonna go play with myself today
so see so he's a play for I think
Alabama was drafted by the Jeff he's
late last year yeah
yeah any fun thank you what position
he's played something Maggie tackled
okay all right so this is a zoom meeting
with the Vallejo planning Commissioner
and then he you see it in the meeting if
you watch the whole clip he actually you
can see him like holding a beer like
walk getting ready to set up and then
you could tell he's pretty excited a few
drinks and then throws his cat so he see
which one he's one Bob left let me get
the highest quality video here hold on
you would like to make let me just save
on next is Commissioner of plaques or
Commissioner Platzer do you have any
comments that you would like to make yes
if I'm allowed to make yes this is this
is the section where I you can
Commissioner that's a cat I know there's
on his feet yes they always do looks
more like a talk and this word though
the meanings he hit the drinker that was
an on how they saying that's bad you
have to raise all this [ __ ] did he lose
his job as an autonomous he resigned
Chuck he resigned thrown that cap I
guess he had too many people talking
throw that was just this you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
where's my cat he likes his cat [ __ ] off
I don't know if he likes his cat but I
think he was sick of them I think he was
sick of his cat [ __ ] just making a lot
of sounds so my caddy were like this
ain't just he just good but you don't
too much a droll
[ __ ] play it again [ __ ] but the cat
I don't think you should lose his job
but he definitely threw the cat the cat
the cat if I went like this the cats
like oh yeah hands on its feet well all
tested what squeaks to surprise defense
he didn't go like this not like this
right how he plays with these cat
does it one small cats play on their
feet no your shitty timeframe because
the cat was meowing why stones the cat
was like good Jimmy Burke was walking
down the street and he came over to
house like what happened he goes I [ __ ]
him right in front of me I'm walking on
Street right in front of me I just a cat
just went and hit the ground went bounce
right up to and just [ __ ] die they
fell out up treat it fell out a 50-story
window we die yes in New York oh hey
anyone like this tea yeah kind of
whiskey is that 17
it's a beautiful whiskey man you want to
take a finger take a poll yeah I'm a man
yeah I'm good take that curl to pull for
daddy yeah it's all filled up on
adderall just do it
Oh Oh daddy like Daddy like I love that
whiskey it's a beautiful whiskey Rashida
it's just such a good whiskey oh yeah it
feels so good it really is it's really
smooth you like your deep down your
throat yeah yeah uh yeah but that's it
whiskey adderall this is the drug this
is the drug podcast this you and here
you'll not become addicts since
quarantine I can understand Alex and I
want to officially say I'm done with
this [ __ ] shutdown and I think I you
know every up us believe me you're not
your governor your your governor he just
puppet leave that down - no I don't pay
50 [ __ ] and may 15th you know we're
gonna do all right we're gonna reassess
we'll see if we open up for ya this
one-man rule in California this
[ __ ] I don't agree with it oh
you don't know and there's nothing I can
do
in that great it makes me so angry you
know what tell me what the death rate is
mother tongue oh I know that's right
that's not you sir that Shawn I are the
same
I know it's ridiculous you know I
thought about you know I like it so far
you're saying you know because I read
that it was like one man running the
state it's up to him when we happen I
was thinking about this morning starting
a revolution ah you know what if you're
gonna shut us down there's no way they
can control the mass I agree if we all
went [ __ ] you and I think we should take
the mortality rate and we're fine
we didn't they think his master
community by may would you say Sweden's
gonna have a herd immunity by May Sweden
got out there and never had to shut down
and just did it smart and then and they
think the infection rate in California
0.147 percent does so many more people
have it think we think [ __ ] you know
what though you know what we need though
Papa you know we need Papa you know your
new [ __ ] cuz new Sims games like shut
your [ __ ] mouth yeah well [ __ ]
nuisance I know he'll move cuz he runs
the Stan
so [ __ ] you little baby you might want
him out of office shut your mouth cuz
you're not leaving you well I got a
problem because I don't live in a
representative government cuz my
government and now you got an F ouchie
and the other health bureaucrats talking
about immunity patients alright so what
we gonna say now I was gonna say what I
was saying was oh what we need is Ohio
parts of Texas and who else's
environment and Florida so they're
they're open stuff back up yeah I
thought everything like the flood get
you have to open certain things back up
certain parts of Texas you [ __ ]
morons not all of Texas yeah but certain
parts of Texas Ohio Atlanta we need to
make sure there's no heavy outbreak
during that understand and when they see
that then it was like oh what are we
doing what do we do is the other thing
your Papa you know realized it's really
it's an election year so the Democrats
California they want the economy being
[ __ ] because that Trump's thing is
that's what I visit well why is the
media want they will they report
everything here this flap yeah well why
would it seems like the media just is
looking for bad news they can't wait to
promote it they want the shutdown last
they want businesses to fail they want
the economy to be a disaster and from
what I can tell I'll say it out loud
from what I can tell if you are not if
you don't have morbidities if you are
not eighty this is not that deadly a
disease from what I can tell and from
what I've seen with the data and I've
paid attention it seems to me that this
is no deadlier than the flu social
distancing no social distancing that's
what it seems I don't know but I'm
starting to know and that's what the
debt that's what the data seems to be
pointing towards and I don't think a
shutdown and keeping everybody negative
for so long
I think we do have to build it hurt
immunity we know you we know that we're
all gonna get it eventually like there's
certain things you can't but the models
that Gavin knew some of these people
were predicting two million a hundred
thousand ninety-five percent of
Californians will be infected get the
[ __ ] out of here with your bias science
which is not science they keep talking
science I don't think so
that professor from Stanford who's an
epidemiologist there's a really really
learning guy he looked at that diamond
princess he said out of like what nine
hundred people at 700 700 [ __ ]
passengers most of whom were elderly
seven died all of whom had underlying
conditions he goes that's a pretty good
[ __ ] and he got pilloried by the
press and by everybody else he got
attacked for being optimistic and
suggesting that maybe the models that
these health experts were going my are
faulty meanwhile we shut everything down
the [ __ ] oh here's something else I got
for you for your ass how about the
people who are dying who are under 65
who are dying all them have underlying
health issues that's exactly right
people were out of shape so here's the
thing dude get in shape here's the
problem you have these underlying health
issues there's give me something run
your life um but my lifetime that's
gonna be way worse than this so if you
were if you're out of everyone you
should hit ruin the entire because it's
a laugh pandemic for you but for me my
kids yellows up for the other [ __ ] man I
agree so if it's killing people are out
of shape and underlying health issues
take [ __ ] notice man get your fat ass
and [ __ ] we have to have a targeted
quarantine and take care of the people
that are vulnerable
yes seize five and over stay inside safe
quarantine six seven over cheering 74
and over because the last time I saw was
if you're 74 and on my dudes know if
you're 74 and observing them with no
[ __ ] underlying health issues you
have a what what was it point oh six
point six percent chance of dying and
then you know what some of the people
are doing well listening so you know
that's not true and they send you fax
that some CNN should though you know
it's not true listen [ __ ] any stat you
send me I can send you one back we can
play that game do the research for
yourself figure it out all I know is the
media just loves this [ __ ] they [ __ ]
love negativity they're all thriving off
the negative and scaring everyone
everybody's here basis for the mascot
sucked in this last year shutting
everything down and Europe that is lying
what [ __ ] what did the Chinese
Communist Party is lying oh oh they are
lying I forgot yeah they always love
what else got Ching get us off this
crumb gavin newsom a billion dollars
with a chinese company for four masks
one billion dollars
he gave half the money up front wears
masks apparently we haven't seen him yet
huh dealing with China again huh gasps
cool you should [ __ ] that guy that's
what I think you know I'm saying though
there's a reason why all these
democratic states they're gonna be the
last
swish California we're gonna be the last
open because reelection and Trump his
main thing is business thriving business
thriving economy the economy before all
this happened was crushing it so by them
slowing down and it's reelection is
they're gonna make Trump again I agree
I think everyone's not buying it I think
that's probably that I think that is a
real very real possibility I'm cynical
enough to believe that that is the
coordinated come on I had to get
scientist cut chin this girl ELISA
Granato she was one of their first
volunteers to do a trial vaccine for
kovat and then she's also a scientist
and then multiple news outlets reported
that she died Nancy Pelosi cut her
throat so this is what it says right
this from news and tea first of all turn
UK corner virus vaccine trial has died
who's the long face lady here in the
picture she's not that so she's not dead
and then she had to post about it
afterwards and here's her long face said
but the [ __ ] media fan she's dead huh
yes it's a doctor I'm glad she's okay me
too
great eyebrows good for a good person
yeah so that's all the bad news though
I've never looked at media ever the same
now since you've been through this I was
never trust them they've lost all
credibility
I'll watch Fox News and that
everything's positive it's all pro-trump
you watch CNN it's all negative it's
Armageddon and then you it's a gentleman
yeah
bless your chin that's it I'm not done
or you want to know this Mike Tyson said
he probably got his Tigers for
the tiger came oh you know I believe him
that that's not even a great story
though but his Tigers are awesome
remember he would play with them
what does he still have the tag no I
said he was he was kind of thinking back
he was such a mistake
ya know one day if he was just playing
with it even when they're just playing
with you they will kill you they
accidentally kill you Tigers yeah I
never understood that
me neither well he's such an alpha the
cat scent oh I wouldn't get a tiger
doesn't feel like an alpha move to me if
you're playing around with the dog
that's pretty alpha I don't think like
that I'm bored it was like on its game
like Tarzan something that guy's crazy
his teeth seen this guy swear you don't
jack off them he's like pretty shredded
and it's like all these animals like
wrestle the [ __ ] you know that is that's
the son of he's talking about the son of
this guy the real Tarzan was thinking
they see everything
Oh black guy yeah
why would you think you know what what
of it brighter what of it dude fight you
talk white guy I didn't know even any
black guys who are into this that's a
white white person [ __ ] this guy gets
millions and millions of views for just
different posts with animals no see but
I think I'm with Brian on this one I was
thinking of a white guy with long hair
who like to jump out of the bush and
tackle it so that guy is I think the Sun
isn't he the son a son of one of the
owners of the guy from the from Tiger
yeah yeah yeah octo yeah that's the guy
you don't talk about chin I notice a
video of that [ __ ] tiger it was it
how you're doing that's what it did to
me when I tried to fever so terrifying
geez
[Music]
yeah kill you in that space now Wildman
yeah it's just their mother Patti the
thing though over the past hundred years
97% of the world's Tigers have
disappeared yeah in 1900 there were
100,000 Tigers in the wild now there's
only 3,200 well tell your first nice
where is this guy from Florida I think
Miami yeah this was known who I was
thinking of his page is a little point
the other guy's pages my boy
I know you talked about your son's name
yes ponytail right yeah when he tells
riving tell the guy who submitted a
video for King listing yep I think his
name is Cody Cody Cody something
so that's history right there that's
Henry yeah that's him there Perry is
Marion's yeah let's see if we can find
out yep just this guy plays a big
carrier low areas that's him look at him
computer that last pages oldest students
okay Ansel humping these goddamn animal
yes doesn't fun
now let's go to a mr. champs he does it
all oh dude I only said I was watching a
Sikh friggin roid the documentary on
them too
yeah that cat got the homeboys never
show it I don't believe this
now think of this this guy's page
compare the last dudes is given a
[ __ ] Tiger Peter skinny guys how
about the Tigers just like God these
guys got five wives hanging them does he
a father takes another [ __ ] level
look at Liam he's gonna inherit that zoo
it's a bit of a smaller Tiger though
yeah it does look fight that sounds like
fun though I'll give him attack I would
never do it and his feet are filthy but
here's my is it does like fun yeah
there's a big reason he's in the Tarzan
boy don't know that's a liger that's a
liger Brennan that's how [ __ ] light
yeah like just kind of lame you know
veigar's are big cats tigers look like
Jordans you buy in downtown and look at
that [ __ ] cat and they can hear this
this pattern is just kind of like fatal
wow that's a Leica dude this is good man
it's not though yeah good let's see the
[ __ ] gym with a [ __ ] cheetah
there's no that's a facade cheetah
that's a yog warred they're very
dangerous
you don't want my voices what's
Photoshop that's fine no it's not messy
yeah no that's definitely Photoshop I
think is just the Sun hitting his face
oh that's Photoshop kids I think it's
definitely touched up that's a painting
that would be a painting I'm sure there
are some of him in that but that was a
fake picture no oh that's watch that
video though okay with that video wanna
play the music though this is the one
that I saw what's this sorry guys we
cannot play the music so just hang tight
for a little bit it's so cool and even
here it's pretty cool and here as well
do you know how balls-deep you up to me
in the animals to [ __ ] get that
comfortable with them I mean I wouldn't
do that with a dog no mmm-hmm swimming
with him and [ __ ]
he plays if she bong ZZZ and she Ponzi's
are good but look at this thing that
[ __ ] tiger he's sucking that diving I
guess they're just like big cats they
just want to be pet sometimes until
they're like to help starving today
cool dude yeah [ __ ] like you're in
the middle
come on Brennan you're drunk
what is that teeth
and here as well there's our shitty
little teeth yeah they're not that I
will sock that [ __ ] tiger in the face
all righty pretty crazy though right
yeah yeah that's living its truth you
know lévesque truth
now that's Amateur champ right better
the darker face so the one love to get
older their faces get dark all right
they're driving drones yeah this guy's
just balls deep in these animals yep
he's scratched up - well that's scar for
sure sure mr. strike here right there
[ __ ]
Yeah right good life though you know
hopefully those beautiful hands giant
[ __ ] hands
see those are beautiful hips the bill to
rip your dong off those are dong rippers
call those the dong rippers that guy has
a great page though let's give a shout
out what's his name Cody and tall mantle
two million followers I think he's doing
all right yeah Oh check it out Myrtle
Beach the fire is open you can go the
right we should fly all right it's
[ __ ] go there now Myrtle Beach Safari
I'll go they give us a nice little tour
I'll do it might be a problem to fly
down there though right now right I
don't know I'm just not comfortable
Tigers dude I just know they scare me
Asham ballsy I'd love to I'd love to say
hi to ashy palsy though I have no desire
I don't like gyms they scare me the
board that boring I think the boys are
very smart very smart very smart very
human they're not cute
it was likely people hmm let me see that
thing and also we can't play music here
that's it
this dude knows this [ __ ] animal
those animals Brennan grow up with
animals who's that guy with the
undertaking the Undertaker Oh dime piece
wife his wife is a dime piece mm-hmm
piercing blue eyes very pretty I think
she also used to be in the WWE lately
looks like now I wouldn't do it with an
elephant because now the Fonte can
decide [ __ ] off
let's throw you to the ground and step
on you I don't know if you've ever seen
that but what elephants do when they get
mad at you their owners their owners
that raise them many times they will
start to kick you around and then grab
you by the trunk and pull you apart and
mash you in today did you see one dude
with a giraffe the draft was like listen
dude I don't like this he a douche and
killed him yeah he killed him that was
the photographer but with with elefantes
they don't bring a belfie own people but
mash you've not talked so please do I'll
mash you nothing better that was the
elephants in the circus it will Matthew
I'm [ __ ] sick now I'm like I know but
dance nothing goes you know what I'm not
feeling anymore hey cool face check out
my just happening and killing buffalos
instead of Pinot lactulose they [ __ ]
mash it into a paste you really want to
watch one of these this is terrible
no I know it's terrifying out of respect
for the people right we know they do
though yeah you don't have to walk
around yeah okey-dokey okay well [ __ ]
your face monday was a good a good
runner Gallic cow on Monday yeah this
adderall Monday that on Monday it's half
an adderall it's okay sometimes it on
Monday no it's not stay away from it
dule dude you don't too much rugs
certain molecules can send you into a
tailspin I think as far back as they
even as recorded history they have
stories of people taking drugs oh yeah
even the Indians were tuned on plants in
general as techs we're doing wild chimp
mushrooms oh yeah always the quest to
get out of your state your current state
you have always been human mm-hmm what
else is there out there what
psychedelics very cool the Amazon
they've got all kinds of she lick a
frog's oh yeah all that [ __ ] have you
guys all done mushrooms yes I have not
you have not you you are not drugs happy
we need to get you on the adderall Oh No
no the ass I would never do acid why
just the name since I can get 10 as a
kid there's a story going around that
some guy did acid then thought he was an
orange and peel his skin yes how
[ __ ] lots of is I've heard good
things about us had never done I'll do
it if you do it that doesn't make anyone
you and I've done other things did DMT
together that was the best thing ever
might be the best thing ever was it I
thought so it was all right oh I thought
it was felt like I have to I would do it
100 I would do it again yeah I never
think about it we're not drug I mean
it's like it's not like it change your
whole you know anytime anybody tells you
about a transformation I saw this guy
dude I'm telling you he takes you doing
it from like I chant like get the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah no man I don't know you
never heard anyone who's happy going I
did this drug and it changed my life man
I'm so much better that's right that's
right that's right I agree never date a
chocolate barn
[ __ ] found a way I think psychedelics
can have positive effects I'm not a big
psychedelic guy but I'll be done try
Rogan is pretty articulate about it you
know I don't know there's a bunch of you
up but you'll swear by if it works for
you do it Sam Harris talks about it in
his book spirituality without religion
you know there's certain things that can
give you a perspective me a certain
psychedelics but I like the reset idea
yeah yeah psychedelics resetting well
the reset you're like if you have
anxiety if you have some sort of stuff
issues your brain - like I think all of
this is whatever I think at the end of
the day human beings have a purpose find
out what your purpose is and follow it
to its end and try to be excellent at it
I think that is the first thing and then
the other stuff you can do on the side
but the first thing is what do you what
are you supposed to do stand up you know
how do you stand on ever the challenge
never goes away you're always learning
about yourself you're always you know
and whatever you do besides that okay
but follow your to hear the rest this
motivational talk 1999 follow your
adderall and - adderall you get it you
get an adderall and you get these talks
like kids do a Nadder although you give
motivational speech at the end I didn't
tell kids to do that at all you
[ __ ]
stop it's not characterizing me as a
pusher does it feel better than in the
world yes the point is you shouldn't do
it O'Malley
can we give it to kids god damnit I
gotta get out of here
hello is that it a million dollars call
me when you're serious Gavin who do we
have on Wednesday nobody this Wednesday
Josh wolf Wednesday I think we do yeah
we have Josh wolf did you yep alright
alright this the final kid route